it's a hidden track and wife Wow  [Music]  there were dragons when I was a boy  where they went only a few know our  story changed the world forever  we did it the world's first dragon  Viking utopia Julia don't be a baby  mine's less Claire did it more Oh Santa  honey hey bud wait up  oh he's not the only one she's a light  fury oh sorry did he just disappear  [Music]  Wow  it's a hidden dragon worth  toothless go introduce yourself has a  girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury  except yours and him over I will never  give him up then I will destroy  everything Yuri love  we are no longer safe here we all have  to disappear completely off the map we  have to fight for their freedom  [Applause]  [Music]  you don't nothing without your dragon  [Music]  show them what you got but  [Music]  save him  as you and me bud always  [Music]  you